est ce que vous connaissez anémone la
comédienne à peine de non louis
j'appréciais la wii est ce que à votre
avis est là et d'avoir été la première
dame de france dans sa carrière pour
faire du cinéma
est-ce que vous l'appréciez c'est très
court à ce qu'on l'apprécié je n'aime
pas les gens visuel pour les bulgares
oui je sais elle a aidé représentative
de l'ensemble du
couches sociales enfin très répandu
finalement est-ce que celle là et
d'avoir été la maîtresse de valéry
giscard d'estaing pour démarrer sa
carrière à votre avis jilian totalement
ce genre de choses était mariée pendant
un an valéry giscard d'estaing et tire
et ça l'a propulsé est ce que ça vous
choque
mais ça ne m'intéresse pas je me sens à
des années lumière d'une personne pareil
sur une nouvelle faute de goût le matin
en vous habillant pas du tout moi la
femme d'un président et a tourné un film
humain ça me choque
anémone elle vous choque le sam est
chaud regarde aller sur le plateau dit
lui anémone a dit puisque vous en pensez
enfin c'est pas momonne surpoids sur le
fait qu'elle ait fait des films nu alors
qu'elle était la première dame de france
c'est la première dame de france à faire
deux films nuits où nous en afrique est
vraiment c'est choquant moi je ne
connais pas ce que j'ai à dire regardez
les photos tous les moyens sont bons
pour accéder à la célébrité
voilà vous l'approuvez oui puisque voilà
maintenant et plus avec jusqu'à
rebooster elle est connue elle a eu tout
à gagner et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux